in one of the most important games of
the season the golden knights gateway
with a loss to colorado thanks for
joining us here at 11 o'clock i'm denise
valdez and i'm brian loftis the cards
were stacked against the team tonight
but there is still hope for them to win
the division sports director chris
matthews live in studio with more
on where the team goes from here yeah
you guys i'll tell you what there was so
much running on this game let's show you
what unfolded at the fortress everything
was sitting right in front of the
knights they controlled their own
destiny when you were in the west
division title and the president's cup
trophy and here we go
boy you could feel this was a biggie
inside that place tonight for the first
time in 11 years
an nhl team going with just 15 skaters
knights missing a handful of players but
scoring first alex petrangelo lights a
lamp
vegas is on the board his sixth 7 500
fans loving life and checking out alex
tuck
kicking himself boy he'll never have a
better opportunity
misses the wide open that oh so close if
you could rewind time
it was one nothing after one to the
second abs score
and they would also score in the third
they add two goals here
two to one vegas had one shot on goal in
the final ten and a half minutes
and the ads beat the knights two to one
was your final
i think obviously this time of year you
want to be playing well going into
going into playoffs um obviously would
have been nice to
to get that win and um you know kind of
reflect
uh on the season uh knowing that the
standings for us were set
but at the same time this group doesn't
uh
doesn't sit back we'll be ready to play
on wednesday we'll get our rest
and be ready to go it's just
everybody plays a couple extra minutes
that's just the way it is
all right now the knights still have a
chance to win the west division and that
president's cup